hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger on
and you might be able to tell this video
turned out a little bit longer than I
was initially hoping for and I'm also
recording this in the morning pretty
early on so maybe things won't go as
smoothly as I would like them to go but
in any case I think this is going to be
an interesting episode in terms of
what's going on in planet coaster
because all I'll be doing in those 14
minutes which accounts for that's that's
over eight hours of in-game footage even
including some of the things that are
left how it is just building a station
that's right I'll be building a single
building throughout this entire episode
but it's going to be one of my favorite
buildings so far of course I can't tell
whether it's actually going to be
positively received or anything but for
me personally this has been one of the
most fun builds that I've had recently
and I would just love to share it yeah
here we go so right here at the
beginning of the time-lapse I think you
can already see why this building took
such a long time to do I tried to build
this building with the in-game roofs at
first sort of doing a bit of a field
test and seeing how I should sort of
translate what I was thinking of into
the game and the in-game roofs just
didn't really work for what I was
looking for so much of my work actually
went into making custom roofs some of
these roof shingle roofs and the reason
that I wanted to make it custom is just
because all of the curves and shapes of
the roof structure that I had in mind
for the building were pretty much
impossible with the in-game roofs and to
be honest there are quite a few other
advantages of using these custom roofs
as well it just means you have much more
much more control over the texture the
way it looks the colour that it has as
well since the shingles actually can go
a tiny bit darker and more saturated I
think than the in-game roofs and even on
a lighting level it works out quite well
since you can see there's a very slight
height difference between each shingle
they're slightly rotated
and overlapping each other as you would
with real shingle roofs which means that
when the Sun is on the other side of the
roof you can actually see those small
shadows underneath the shingles and
could see the the very small lighting
differences between the shingles and
that's a very subtle thing but I think
it makes the overall appearance of the
roof and the way that it reacts to the
lighting in game a lot better but most
of all it's not so much a texture reason
as I religious wanted to have a very
specific shape for the roof it doesn't
matter too much for the things that I'm
working on at the moment since these are
just Gables and just straight gabled
roofs which is something that is also
just possible with the game itself but
most of these roofs will actually be
hips roofs so they'll have this high
kneecap on the side sort of as you can
see on the the higher part of the roof
right here and there simply aren't
really any great pieces to make hip
roofs in the game especially not on this
scale there are a few corner roof pieces
but they're much too large and either
too steep or not steep enough to work
for the thing that I'm going for here
and I'll also get into some spires and
towers later on so using the shingles to
make the entire roof just means that the
roof texture of the spires will actually
match the roofs exterior of the roof
yeah that's all of my reasoning and the
actual building of the roof was an
entirely different matter
I really thought at first that this was
going to be somewhat easy but I think I
always just underestimates how how
difficult things become and it wasn't so
much that it was difficult to do as you
can see I really just filled in the
outline of the roof which I'll get to in
a minute at the beforehand so I didn't
really have to figure out the exact
placing of all the roofs but it just
takes quite a while to get all of these
shingles in at the right places make
sure that they all have a similar
overlap so it doesn't look like they're
all stitched together awkwardly and many
of these corners
on the outside of the roofs but also on
the inside over here I had to be quite
careful with because I didn't want them
to intersect that's actually another
reason partly why I like to use these
custom roofs because it means that you
can have full control over the shaping
you don't really have roof sticking out
in the interior of the building and the
interior can all just be fixed with a
simple sealing and other than that just
look clean see the outline of the
building was a slightly different method
that was one of the things that I didn't
record but that I'm still actually quite
fussy about it's the sort of general
composition of the building that I
really wanted to figure out before the
time lapse I don't think it's something
that's fun to watch in time-lapse since
the the way that I do it and the way I
like to do it is to just place roofs and
walls everywhere in a sort of
composition that I think I might go for
and just take a bit of distance and look
at it kind of as if you were looking at
a painting from a distance I suppose and
just keep working at Matt's until I have
a general shape that looks good the
building would still look terrible it
really looked horrible in my first
sketches since it's just the shape that
I was going for so the roofs and the
walls and everything were very ugly but
at least it gave me an idea of what sort
of composition I want to have for this
building which means that I don't have
to do that part in the time lapse
anymore and otherwise the time lapse
would become a whole lot of moving
things and looking at the building as a
whole which doesn't really translate in
a good time s so I actually really like
to do this thing beforehand it's also a
little bit embarrassing I guess in a way
to watch back those sort of those sort
of time lapses because even though I
want to keep these time lapses as raw as
possible it's really a whole lot of
making terrible looking things until you
get somewhere where it really sort of
clicks and you're happy with where it
goes so yeah that's basically the point
where I'm continuing this video now I
need to catch up a bit again
I'm falling behind them a 40 minute
video which is kind of ridiculous in and
of itself
I'm adding
small foundation layer at the bottom of
the building with some of these custom
bricks there's actually a brick trick
that I used quite a while ago on a
mansion I'm not sure what I call it but
I think it was still the alpha version
of the game where just before an update
came around I think I built this sort of
I call it Iron River but it wasn't even
that flashy but a simple mention to try
and work with some of the textures the
wall textures and roof textures that you
can make yourself so I sort of brought
that experiment back for the foundation
of the building which in terms of color
and texture I'm actually quite happy
right it does bring that sort of console
/ mention / palace sort of vibe to it
it's very much a classical brick texture
in that sense and this is probably the
part where the real style of the
building will come out and that's
something that I actually wanted to talk
about quite a bit because this building
is not just any Alpine style
I find it difficult to say that there's
just a very generic Alpine style it
feels like there there is one in theme
parks if you just have a lot of wood
large overhanging roofs with large eaves
and white stucco everywhere you're
getting somewhere toward a certain
alpine style in general and I think that
works fine that's something that I also
just like to do as well
but in this case I wanted to go for a
more distinct style one that's not even
that common and really placed in a very
small part of history and right now
isn't really a thing anymore unless it's
just revival and that's the Swiss Chalet
style it's a sort of Alpine style but
it's much more highly decorated its most
recognizable in this building probably
by all of the carvings and these
decorations that I'll be placing and one
of those carvings is what I'm working on
right now if this were just a simple
Alpine building these would probably
just be
simple wooden posts without really any
decorations but since I'm trying to
build in the Swiss Chalet style these
are some of the elements that I want to
decorate most and get all of these
carvings into because that's what the
style is really all about and there were
quite a few inspirations for this
building which I can probably talk about
as well since it's something that I
still feel I'm sort of lacking in my
videos so most of the expressions of
course were Swiss Chalet style buildings
some of them were even in Switzerland
although the style was sort of spread
around Europe as a whole in the 1900s
lots of Swiss Chalet style buildings in
Germany also in the Netherlands there
are quite a lot funnily enough I think
that Baron 1898 actually has a station
with some slides Swiss Chalet style
influences if you look at the front
facade of the entrance of the queue you
can actually see those those gable
decorations that you would see in
special a style buildings that's quite
interesting there's also some
Scandinavian Swiss Chalet style but
that's slightly different think they
also call it the dragon style it's with
all of these lines wooden decorations on
the roofs for instance but yeah I'm
basically just following mystery style
here so probably my biggest inspiration
is the daughter Grand Hotel which is
actually in Switzerland and it's in Ooty
excuse me for my terrible German
pronunciation but it's it was a big
inspiration for me since I'm working on
the station building and I knew that I
wanted to get quite inspires in there
and make it very console-like and very
fantasy like but the Swiss Chalet style
is as the name suggests a style that
evolved out of just Swiss chalets which
are just small residential homes and not
something that you'd build an entire
console out of so I was looking for some
inspiration that with a key on the
larger skills since I didn't want the
station to look like a home but rather
more of a palace or a castle so I was
looking for those kinds of integrations
and
the daughter Grand Hotel is actually
sort of an overblown sugar-coated
ridiculous sort of revivalist the hotel
buildings actually it is really
beautiful I almost felt like those were
a lot of very negative adjectives but
it's quite a beautiful building even if
it is a bit fairytale esque and a bit
over-the-top in a sense and that was
kind of large inspiration because it
combines the sort of the sort of Alpine
Swiss style with a lot of towers spires
and furry Belle Epoque decorations in
general which I also have to say now
that I'm on the rent which is all over
the place anyway this has been a very
Belle Epoque style it was around around
the 1900s which means that it comes with
all sorts of other awesome little
scenery things that I'll be getting to
in the rest of the series like our
Nouveau lampposts and that sort of stuff
but that's not something for the next
episode which I'm probably going to
spoil here so I'm not going to be
talking about about that too much but
it's a time period in terms of
architecture that I really love it was
just before modernism came around the
corner and it was an area where people
were experimenting a lot with reviving
old styles and eclecticism bringing all
sorts of different styles together it
was before everything sort of became
very modern and
Marie is simple but not too simple but
minimalist which is something that I
like as well but especially when I'm in
theme parks I just prefer to have
traditional architecture and sort of the
Golden Age idea that you otherwise don't
really see anywhere I might be a bit of
an architecture revivalist although I
also just like modern buildings as well
anyway that's a conversation I don't
want to go into too much it is the time
period that I love with a lot of
architectural styles that I really love
and a lot of general it's just
interesting to play around with it it's
something that just sort of steals from
other time periods it's not so much its
own style but it's a lot of revival now
anyway another building that I was very
inspired by that more reflect the color
scheme that I went for is a building in
and I think this is Germany although I
don't want to be wrong about this
it's in sunked blossom which is a
building where where there is a building
called cow cows bison burger or at least
they used to be and now his different
name but it's building that also was a
bit of an inspiration because it has
these very typical Swiss style gable
roofs with decorations and a nice little
tower on the top of the building and
those are basically two buildings that
combined make make up a lot of the
inspiration for this building actually
collected a whole lot of pictures of
Swiss Chalet style buildings that also
were much of an influence in this build
but I think that those two were really
the two that you can most easily find in
this building even though I didn't
directly take any elements from it
especially no they were used to get
certain directions like what kind of
color scheme should I use what kind of
gable decorations can you use in certain
like in certain places it's that sort of
stuff that I look for when I'm looking
for inspiration which by the way is such
an important part I still see a lot of
people sometimes struggling to find
inspiration or to find something to work
off of for me it's not so much trying to
find something to just rebuild it but
more look around and see what kind of
elements you can add within a certain
style so I might take inspiration for
the roof structure from the same from
one building then take inspiration for
the gable decorations from another
building take inspiration for the
cornices from another building that sort
of that sort of idea just again an idea
of what kind of look and feel the
buildings of a certain style are going
for in general now I'm behind it
terribly again so here I'm working on
the tower which is the main spire of the
building and really the thing that
elevates the station to be greeny I'm
sort of behind on the gable action as
well I just made a gable decoration on
the front roof which sort of helps to
establish this part of the building as
the actual front and also covers up the
exits park a little bit and I've also
put some of the expires in which is just
a bit of an ER and efteling esque
touch which is something that I also
wanted to talk about on doing that
really surprised me during building this
is how almost sort of a stilling ask it
feels it's a little bit too clean I feel
to really be in the style of the
ethylene and Olympics in particular but
it has that that same slight eclecticism
and all these minor details
the decorated Gables and especially the
little spires on the point of the roofs
which really sort of recall the efteling
to me at least a little bit I can
imagine that if the ethylene had built
another station for their Swiss bulb
which they put more budgets into their
current station that they had it could
almost kind of look like something like
this built which is just I don't know
something that surprised me a little bit
I don't know enough about architecture
to say exactly where that lies but
it was something funny that I kind of
thought of while building this building
so as a little sidestep that I took
while I was making the spire I also
wanted to make a small window on the
front of it just as a little decoration
I felt the roof was a little bit too
empty otherwise and much like the spires
in what was the name again the daughter
Grand Hotel I wanted to try and get
these sort of two steps powers in here
so we have the lower half then we have a
small bell tower section with some
wooden pillars and then there's the top
off of the tower which is one of these
things which I haven't really read
anything about but it's an element which
actually comes back in a few other of
these which style buildings that I found
as well but especially in the Grande
Hotel where it has this sort of steps
approach to it which also kind of helps
because it makes the spire a bit taller
as well and I'm just event with really
narrow tall spires over small tiny low
spires all kinds of spires have their
own Beauty to it but I just love the
kind of very elaborate spires that get
much more narrow and sort of elongated
as they get towards the top now here was
a slightly more difficult point I didn't
want the spire to be straight so there's
a bit of funky yeah not entirely sure
what the comet was just some funky shape
been going on here where it almost
becomes an onion dome inspired build
except it's on a square base and it's a
little bit more tall than that but I
think it helps to round out the spider a
little bit more no pun intended and I
guess make it a little bit more
interesting than if it were just a
simple spire this was actually one of
the things which I ended up
experimenting with a lot of as well some
of the things which you don't see in the
time that is me building something
looking at it from a distance deciding
that it doesn't really
and trying something else instead of
repeating that process and for the
longest time I was doubting whether I
wanted to put the second layer on the on
the station building and whether I
wanted this to be this sort of decorated
tower or whether I just wanted it to be
a straight Tower as the lower half is
and in the end I just excited to go with
this method since I think it just also
kind of offsets how straight all of the
rest of the roofs are it just makes it a
little bit more clear that hey this is
the main spire this is the big
decoration that sort of signifies the
station building and that even sort of
makes it act like a wing in the sense
that from a lot of the sight lines that
you see this station from the first
thing that you do see is that tiny
little top spider which still even like
crowds above the trees and above the
rollercoaster from the other side of the
park so it's it's a funky little
elements I think it is a near exact copy
though of the spires the dollar Grand
Hotel don't try to start turning me
saying the words fire into drinking game
Parker way that's a bad idea just want
to put that in here before the comment
section goes wild but it's slightly
different in terms of the angles of the
roofs but it's it's very similar it's
it's almost a copy of that anyway which
I kind of feel a little bit bad about
but then again every spire has been
built at some point in time and there's
hardly any exact combinations that
haven't been tried and it just works out
too well not to use it so there's that
and here's a bit of other work that I
just had to get in on the frontier I
wanted to cover the front of the station
a little bit since one of the signifying
elements of this way style is that it
has a lot of balconies and
decorative carvings brackets wooden
posts that sort of stuff but in order to
actually get those in you kind of do
need to force some elements into the
building which you need them for
so some covered roofs without walls that
allow you to get all of this wood in is
something that I was looking for and on
the right side of the station I've sort
of achieved that with the table of the
front roof and also the carvings on the
right side here where we have that small
sort of carving section underneath the
enormous Eve of the building but on the
left side we have the exit path and I
figured why not just cover that have a
roof over it
which means that it's included into the
building a little bit more and also
gives us some extra space to add these
carvings and wooden posts so I'm just
trying to get as much as the lower sort
of overlapping parts as I can get in
here now on the back side I have a
similar situation going on although this
is slightly different and there is a
sort of yeah I wouldn't exactly call it
the kettle pan since it's super small
and the roof doesn't actually cover the
kettle pan so I'm not sure that analogy
actually works but there's a sort of
small entrance queue line little
covering of the roof over here the issue
was that I wanted to make this station
look good from pretty much every angle
and I'm not sure whether I succeeded
with it although I'm pretty happy with
it in the end one of the major issues
that I found was that the backside still
was a little bit more neglected when
compared to the front side of the
station so I wanted to put something in
here to decorate this side of the
station a little bit more and make the
entrance of the queue into the station a
little bit better and I figured one of
these lower sections that sort of
attached to the building but not really
structurally part of the building itself
could work quite well for it it's really
one of these sort of Victorian galleries
which this is inspired by and yeah
that's basically it it's very similar to
the rest of the building in terms of the
way that everything is decorated I
really just took a lot of the same posts
and spiral decorations although it does
have a slightly different roof and I
won't be putting it on the exact same
foundation as the rest of the building
so it's just a part that sort of juts
out and covers the queue for a little
bit now skipping ahead again a bit I
shaved out the spire on the side here I
was also not sure for quite a while what
sort of shape I wanted to have for the
spire but in the end I went for a very
simple straight forward spire and if
there's any sort of tip that I can get
out of it for this video is that as a
general rule of thumb what I like to
follow is that my biggest and most
important sort of attention drawing
parts of the building is also where I
wanted to have the most interesting roof
structures and the highest amount of
detail and some of the other points
which I don't want as much of the
attention going are a little bit more
simple so this is the lower tower of the
building it's sort of on the other side
to balance out the other Tower if you
will and also put the tower facing the
other side of the station which would
hopefully make the backside intercession
a little bit nicer as well but since I
didn't want the focus to be on this
tower it's a bit more simple and it's
just a straight forward straight yeah
it's pretty much displayed just a
straightforward simple alpha in spire
which I do have to say just getting this
in very quickly some of my inspiration
is from an unlikely source I'm not even
sure if I would call it even inspiration
at this point anymore it's more sort of
research is actually coming from the
place of rollercoaster country one of my
favorite custom scenery sets ever in
roll across the country and one of the
the sets which probably most well
acoustically players remember is alpine
village by shy guy which has a lot of
different sets and a lot of different
Alpine structures in it and even though
it was really just meant to be used in
Mullica ii 3 as a custom scenery tank
which allows you to build in a style
which tent itself doesn't have
it really premier also became a sort of
way to almost make building Alpine style
buildings in theme parks a natural thing
since all of the gable styles the spire
styles the roof styles have sort of
become natural out of that custom
scenery set and this fire in particular
looks almost exactly like one of the
spires in alpine village I can't
remember exactly in which set of the
seven it was but yeah it's a funny funny
sense I guess of getting expression from
it and I'm sure some players of
rollercoaster you might recognize it if
you didn't play it though I wouldn't
really recommend doing it in high sense
since it's now become terribly aged if
you compare it to planet coaster in
terms of lighting and user friendliness
and pretty much everything but there was
a lot of scenery we played around with
Emma game and I think it's actually sort
of a good guide and a good
yeah source of inspiration to look back
at if you've got nothing else sometimes
I can even just look at rollercoaster in
three builds to get more inspiration for
planet coaster I guess in a sort of
cliche way it doesn't really matter in
what sort of game you build what you
build as long as you can like see the
creativity in it doesn't really matter
but yeah basically that was my little
thing about roller coaster q3 I'll try
not to talk about it any more for an
upcoming few episodes of planet coaster
because I know I talk about a game way
too much going forward into the back of
the station here I'm pretty much just
following the same details as follow the
station trying to throw it all in nicely
and neatly I'll be getting back to that
a little bit but the nice thing is that
I can actually just take the things that
I did at the front side of the station
and copy them over to the back which is
maybe a little bit cheap it was really
the easiest way for me to do it but I
think it also just kind of works out I
think the way that this cable works out
combined with the other cable it's kind
of interesting
oh and something that had just realized
which I'm not sure if I'd ever talked
about this but apparently it's illegal
in Switzerland to have completely flat
roofs I'm not sure to what extent this
is really legislated but apparently it
is officially illegal to have flat roofs
in Switzerland because you need a roof
that rain can actually or water I
suppose can actually just fall over and
a flat roof also wouldn't be safe
apparently I think in terms of snow now
I've also read that many of the actual
mountain homes have roofs that don't
have very steep inclines since that
means that snow is going to lay on the
roof which it's good insulation for the
house but I'm not sure if that's
entirely correct I'm definitely not an
Alpine home expert but what I did do is
try to make sure that all of the slopes
of the roof in this build are somewhat
gentle and that the roof which look like
a flat roof on the frontier is actually
very slightly inclined so in terms of in
terms of you know when it rains it
actually can just glide down toward the
side of the building here I also think
yeah I was going for a sort of metal
corrugated roof on the front but since
the metal corrugated roof in the game
itself looks a little bit too worn down
and dilapidated to use for this sort of
clean build I figured I would try to
sort of make my own one using doors and
that's why it looks like a bit of a
funky roof on the front there or
technically it's on the back here now
you might also notice especially toward
the base of the building here that I'm
actually using a lot of different
buildings instead of building everything
in a single building and the reason why
I wanted to do that is because for one
there's a bit of weirdness going on with
the custom brick walls because they
stick out a little bit but I also wanted
to make sure that I don't have
bricks sticking out through the roofs on
the other side like if you have a
90-degree corner going on here as you
actually just saw sometimes there's a
brick that sticks out on the wrong side
of the wall since I'm using corner
pieces to build these brick walls but
you know there are huge pieces with all
kinds of other sections attached to them
as well that I don't use but that sort
of started sticking through everything
where I don't want them to be so that
was a bit of an issue that I had to work
around with but also the foundation wall
is placed a little bit further than the
actual walls of the building and I
didn't want it to be placed quite as far
away from the rest as you would have if
you place it within the same building
but on the outside of the grid so there
are just separate buildings that very
slightly cut out from the rest of the
building I'm not sure what that noise
all right there cleaning the garbage
disposal that needs outside I hope the
voice isn't too bad and I think I can
really filter that out in any way but I
hope they're gone pretty soon so here
I'm working on some of the hip roofs and
this is clearly one of the things which
I really couldn't do with the in-game
roofs there is one of these small hip
roofs but the issue with a quarter tile
roof that you can rotate and make less
or more steep is that if you make it
less or more steep it's not going to
connect perfectly anymore and you get
these weird parts where the roof juts
out from itself or the texture goes
completely haywire because you're going
to have to rotate the roofs to get a
decent incline so that was something I
didn't want to mess with I just wanted
to have a clean roof so especially for
these hip roofs on the side I needed to
use the yard they cost some roofs plus
everything is overhanging quite a bit as
well so there isn't a lot of leeway so I
also had to use the smallest cornice
pieces in order to make the Gables since
the larger ones would stick out in
places where I didn't want them to stick
out and as you can see these are very
narrow roofs so I was pretty much just
forced to you
as the noise outside just keeps getting
louder and louder
I might have to close my window and look
at that for a little bit I'll do that
right I thought the the source of the
noise pollution was Kara cleaning the
streets so at least the street acclaim
but Harris was not to greater than a
thing going on from my recording in any
case I also wanted to have some
cornerstones to the building there's a
bit of a split between the different
sections of the building and this is an
all topic of mine that I also like to
talk about basically it's the division
of detail and this is one of my personal
biggest struggles and something that I
can spend hours on trying to perfect and
I'll still mess it up and I'll still be
unhappy with my result actually it's the
division of details for me the amount of
details in a building is not so much as
impressive as placing the details in
just the right places I've been told a
super long time ago that you can't
really see the detail anywhere if
there's detail everywhere and you just
need some more empty spaces to balance
out the amount of detail that you'd have
somewhere else and personally I'm not
really a big fan either of buildings
that have details everywhere so in this
case I needed to make a sort of clear
division between what points of the
building would be very busy and very
decorated and what parts would be more
empty and left alone and sort of blank
in that sense so the top half of the
building at least above the sort of
beige border that I have in the middle
of the walls is where I have all of the
wooden details of the wooden carvings
and decorations and then the bottom half
is pretty much just left alone and is
only stone and stucco and why the bottom
parts don't have any of the wooden beams
and speculations on the outside it just
has some corner stones to show where the
corners are I just like the combination
of corner stones and timber not sure
what that is exactly about it I think it
just looks really good so yeah aside
from that there's just some very simple
sort of necessary details going
the bottom half of the station just
doors windows and the occasional
decoration like the hanging planters on
them or the hanging baskets with flowers
I should say on the phone sterling here
at the exit part but aside from that the
the sort of first floor of the building
is left very empty then the bottom again
is quite detailed with all of the
different layers of stone the slightly
different colors the bricks and also the
I would say the pears are kind of
included in that level of detail as well
and then the station again is another
layer or the roof again is another layer
that's not quite as detailed because I
don't personally think that very busy
roofs work out as well with a building
that already has a lot of different
decorations on the walls underneath the
roots so the roof is actually quite
simple and aside from a few chimneys in
the future and some small towers joining
out from it is really just going to stay
the way it is now and here is actually a
bit of a technical thing which is unique
for this episode since the residues
building there is a small transfer track
or transfer table I should say at the
front of the station here since there
was no space to do it at the back of the
station and I do have that beautiful
space that I can just put a storage
building into so yeah the transfer
tables in the prompt of the station this
is a transit direct because it's not
actually one that really moves as much
in any case it's a small piece it's
either it's straight or it's a curved
and I'll have to put some supports and
shouldn't underneath that to actually
support the idea of it being this sort
of a trench attack but there's no
basically very simple friends with
carriages switches between a straight
piece and well that's small group space
I would have actually involved to see
one of these rotating track pieces I
don't know if you've ever seen them but
there are some transfer track pieces
which are for instance a curve on the
top and then underneath that upside down
there with
a straight track piece and the entire
piece use rotates 180 degrees vertically
if a car needs to go to the transferred
wreck which are really interesting
pieces well there are all kinds of
different ways to get coaster cars into
the maintenance shed but in any case
that's what I chose to go for in this
case since it's very compact and it's
divided into the space where I needed it
to fit and it's also more typical of the
mind trains as far as I know I've never
really seen a mind train that moves an
entire track sections with the coaster
car on it into the trends of drag so I
think this is just about the only way
that you can do it although I'm not
entirely sure nut anyway I wanted to
build a quick custom tree over here I
was really unsure for quite a while what
sort of support I wanted for the 3 since
I needed something that was very narrow
very small but also looked like it's
actually at the stem for a small tree I
sort of young saplings if you will so in
the end I don't even remember what three
I said of them just that I was kind of
happy with the results not entirely
happy but I think it works out you know
I was just looking for more variation in
the foliage especially since I'm trying
to avoid certain trees over here such as
the tropical trees which have much more
vibrant colors you might also notice
that actually yeah I did mute almost all
of the colors in iaeger horns so far I'm
using a lot of the much more dull
greyish less saturated foliage I also
use barely any saturated colors
everything is a little bit grayish which
I'm trying to do to make it look a
little bit more realistic a little bit
more rustic since I think climate course
is also beautiful with that very
saturated look especially in Koala Beach
for instance it's something that works
out just perfectly to set the tropical
mood but in this case I want to have
something that's a little bit more
alpine a little more gorilla dish so
everything is a little bit more muted
and I want the foliage to go along
that and also the small custom tree
which I think works out better this way
then taking the tropical small foliage
bushes they're still cleaning up the
streets outside but yeah I think that
works out a little bit a little bit more
better god that was an awful sentence a
little bit better because it's much less
saturated and it gets a little bit again
working on a small chimney here in which
I wanted to decorate as well since
everything about the building just has
to be decorated and there's a small
cover over it as well which I'm not
entirely sure how common it is to see
covers like that these sort of covered
chimneys are quite Co for alpine
buildings I believe but I mean precisely
basis on anything so I'm not sure how
accurate it really is but I'm quite
happy with how it works out it's just a
simple thing one of the things which I
just like most about this building and
this is in no way to brag or anything
and that's also why I'm sort of placing
this at the end of the episode because I
thought it would be kind of bad start
off with it but one of the things which
I'm most happy about with this building
is the fact that I just I love building
it and it's one of these buildings where
during the time that I was building it I
just constantly had to stop the time
that to look at it and just enjoy taking
in the view and to be honest that's
something which I don't really feel that
often usually when I build things it's
just kind of it's a bit Sarah punic but
it's never the sense that I really get
the rush of it how well everything is
going and how much I like it it's a
super rare thing for me to really like
the stuff that I'm doing and in this
build I was just really enjoying it
hence also why this episode might be
over 40 minutes long because I wanted to
finish the station within this one
episode and I just couldn't stop and it
was just too much fun to do it and to be
honest that's still for me one of the
things that motivates me most I've
actually been talking about this with
Rudy today and I actually feel that as
much as it is
wait to have a community around planet
coaster and as much as it is also
motivating to have a lot of people
watching your creations because quite
honestly that's sort of what it's about
and that's why I also think it's always
important to watch the creations of
other people as well and just help each
other out
one of personally pretty much my biggest
motivation is just the feeling you get
when you're building something on it
just works out and this is something
that I I don't feel that often and I
guess that's a bit of a motivator as
well because I know that feeling when
you don't have it for such a long time
and everything you build just doesn't
seem to work out as well and you're not
really inspired to do anything new but
sometimes sometimes I just get into this
move I want to get things done and I
have this thing in mind and it just
works out when I try to build it and
even though it's rare I think it's all
worth it and it's it's an awesome
feeling to have and the most motivating
thing because it's such an intrinsic
thing you're building just for the
feeling that you get when you're
building and not any external other
motivator and really that's why I've
been so happy with this build and why
this is probably my favorite building
that I've ever made in Plymouth coaster
and I know that's a super big thing to
say
but it's one of the buildings that I
enjoyed building most and one of the
buildings I can look back at most and
just take in the view and I'm not
entirely sure why I'm saying this or
what exactly has a viewer you can get
out of this but I find that a lot of
people are sometimes stuck not even just
with the game but with themselves as
well and stuck not really wanting to
play the game and not feeling inspired
and I think the biggest biggest way to
get around that sometimes is to not just
to not just play at all and just wait
for when inspiration comes around and
when you do get it to not care about
whether anybody is going to like it or
whether it's something that you have to
build it's just it's such a really great
feeling to be building something and
just be happy with what you're building
while you're building it
even though it's so rare for me at least
and it's a weird thing to explain as
well if you never really felt that way
it's such a strange thing because it's
creative game and creative gaming and
why exactly it is so motivating
especially in a game which is very even
a game like this anymore it's it's
almost like like painting or making
music really so yeah that was my weird
little talked about that I'm just
finishing up the station over here with
a few more things that I didn't want to
say there's a bunch of body which I
think also makes kind of a big
difference or a bunch of clutter I
should say in the form of barrels ropes
and some some flowers baskets and
actually window box is one which made
quite a difference and that's one of the
things which I think really just helps
to bring in the atmosphere of the
building it's not so much part of the
architectural part of the building but
it's very much part of sending the
atmosphere so even if you have a
building which you're not even that
happy with just try work with it put
some foliage around it to put some some
of this clutter around it make it come
to life and you might actually start
liking it a lot more than you did
initially see how that's been it's for
this super long episode of Jaeger horn I
hope you guys enjoyed if you stayed
through the entire video then big props
I wouldn't be able to but in any case
I'm going to end this video with some
cinematic shots so even for those of you
skipping forward into the end of the
video here's a quick look into what the
station looks like before we add
anything else to the point thanks for
watching and see you later guys
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]